in 1978 the world was still in the grip
of star wars fever so how did everyone
react when the man of steel himself hit
theaters keep watching to find out
even though superman had never featured
in a big budget movie before he was
still an icon one who had appeared in
nearly every other medium imaginable
over the previous 40 years viewers had
built up a very definite image of who
the man of steel was and that meant the
movie had a lot to live up to the
producers turned that handicap into an
asset the same way mgm had with gone
with the wind decades earlier by
promoting superman with a hyped up
global talent search warner brothers was
so determined to get the movie right
that they spent two years on the casting
search which was almost as long as the
rest of the production put together the
whole process was so public that roger
ebert made sure to mention it in his
contemporary review and though hollywood
had done this often enough to make him
skeptical he wrote although talent
searches are usually 100 horse feathers
this time for once they actually found
the right guy
christopher reeve had never appeared in
a movie before but according to producer
elia salkin he won out over hundreds of
other unknowns as well as superstars
like paul newman steve mcqueen and
arnold schwarzenegger
superman hit the screen at just the
right moment in film history it began
pre-production at a bearish time for
sci-fi blockbusters hollywood was still
recovering from its near collapse in the
60s and the few hits it managed to pull
out were mostly dark dramas like the
exorcist and the godfather as for
science fiction audiences mostly had to
choose between two flavors b movie
makers were filling drive-ins with cheap
silly adventures full of laughable
effects and silly
[Music]
performances meanwhile their upmarket
competitors were making more polished
products but these tended to be grim
philosophical movies like soylent green
and 2001 a space odyssey there wasn't
much in between the year before superman
made it to theaters however another
movie changed the whole game star wars
shattered records by combining an
old-fashioned space opera with
newfangled effects technology it proved
moviegoers were ready to have fun again
to the tune of hundreds of millions of
dollars and that's not even counting the
film's absolutely massive merchandising
takings audiences wanted more and while
other studios scrambled to cash in
superman offered the perfect movie to
tide them over while they waited for
star wars 2. warner brothers even
poached the star wars crew for talent to
bring their own vision to life including
the now iconic composer john williams
warner brothers knew what they had with
superman and they didn't want to miss
out on any potential viewers so the
studio made sure everybody and their
mother knew the man of steel was coming
to a theater near them mcleans reported
on the movie's marketing just before it
came out in their appropriately named
super hype cover story according to the
magazine warner brothers estimates that
north americans will have had 7 billion
chances through print radio and tv
advertising to have heard about superman
mclean's placed the movie's advertising
budget somewhere between 6 million to 7
million over 26 million in today's money
the story even runs down a few of the
tie-ins that were available at the time
from books and t-shirts to toys and some
stranger items such as trash cans it's
hard to imagine a scenario in which all
that investment wouldn't pay off but it
was a very real possibility in the
mclean's piece writer ivor davis
reflects on past movies where things
went wrong including a remake of king
kong and the great gatsby adaptation
starring robert redford these movies had
equally massive ad campaigns and equally
safe bet source material but failed to
reach the sky high profit margins the
hype men dreamed of
superheroes had moved off the printed
page and into the movies before 1978.
after so many decades of silver screen
crime fighters however it can be hard to
imagine the impact superman had when it
hit theaters live-action superheroes
have been around almost as long as their
comics counterparts starting with 40s
cereals based on captain marvel batman
and superman himself but hollywood
didn't have enough faith in the source
material to give these projects the kind
of resources they would in 1978 let
alone now instead viewers got baggy
costumes cardboard sets and laughable
plots that barely resembled those found
in the comics until superman the biggest
splash superheroes had made in the media
was in 1966 with the batman tv show
starring adam west holy holy donut
but that couldn't be more different from
what director richard donner did with
superman batman wasn't an adaptation so
much as an officially approved parody
goofing on the whole idea of superheroes
by exaggerating their wackiest aspects
and by the 70s tv super heroing had
moved on to shows like wonder woman and
the incredible hulk which were less
explicitly comedic but still full of
sophie's silliness audiences probably
expected more of the same from superman
but that's not what they got at all the
film treats superman as serious business
and gives his adventures far more
grandeur than other live-action heroes
had enjoyed up to that point anyone who
ever got seriously invested in the
straight face superhero flicks of later
decades owes donner a very large debt
indeed
close encounters of the third kind and
star wars made it possible to bring
moviegoers a whole new kind of superman
earlier versions had led a lot to be
desired in the special effects
department of course the movie's serials
of the 40s had suddenly transitioned to
animation for the flying scenes and in
the 50s tv show actor george reeves hung
from a wire while a fan blew in his face
it took until 1977 for the movies to
finally catch up with fans imaginations
and the filmmakers pulled out all the
stops to make it work the flying scenes
on superman required a combination of
matte effects camera trickery
complicated rigs and physical stunt work
in the form of having to hang
christopher reeve up in the air
sometimes as high as 50 feet the
marketing team summed up the film crew's
accomplishment in a simple phrase that
everyone in america knew by heart by the
time the movie premiered you'll believe
a man can fly there were plenty of other
impressive effects too superman lifted
the innovations of star wars to create a
miniature planet krypton and a
crystalline fortress of solitude that
looked just as real as tatooine or the
death star but that tagline sums up
everything that makes superman work as a
movie suddenly the sight of a live actor
as a comic book hero tights and all was
a cause for awe instead of laughter
when superman was released audiences
were ready for some good old-fashioned
fun star wars had revived the long dead
space opera genre of course but it also
self-consciously nodded at the movies of
the past with techniques such as the
wipe transition and an opening crawl
borrowed from the serials of george
lucas's childhood lucas would later lean
on those retro influences again in his
story for steven spielberg's raiders of
the lost ark superman was part of that
same zeitgeist the special effects were
downright futuristic in 1978 and donner
used them to make a deeply old-fashioned
story fresh again that's certainly how
roger ebert felt at the time writing
superman is a pure delight a wondrous
combination of all the old-fashioned
things we never really get tired of
adventure and romance heroes and
villains earth-shaking special effects
and you know what else wit donner
self-consciously leaned into that aspect
of superman calling on classic stars
like veteran western hero glenn ford as
paw kent and former little rascal jackie
cooper as perry white and the scenes of
superman's youth in smallville kansas
are self-consciously timeless with
classic cars and settings that could
have come out of a norman rockwell
painting as clark kent superman still
wears the same blue suit and fedora he
had in the 40s and while his co-workers
may be more fashionable the atmosphere
at the daily planet nevertheless evokes
the classic newspaper movies of yore
with the benefit of hindsight it's hard
to imagine that superman was anything
but a super safe bet but that wasn't how
audiences felt in 1978 the movie
represented an enormous investment with
its high-tech effects and all-star cast
not to mention the millions upon
millions of dollars warner brothers
poured into the ad campaign all this for
a movie in a genre that didn't really
exist yet too and had only really proven
its viability in other media no doubt
the fate of superman was up in the air
until the final box office tallies came
rolling in in the mclean's article about
the movie it was discussed how warner
brothers might share the prophets of the
movie the article mentions that fact is
only relevant if the movie takes off and
calls that the biggest if in movie
history it goes on to say the
consequences of a super flop could be
dire since warner communications had
been caught in the stock market crash of
1973. in the piece mclean's quotes an
executive who reassures them that the
company is turning a steady profit in
many sectors but they still conclude the
money from a successful movie and from
all the merchandising could make all the
difference apparently it did warner
communications now a t warner media is
bigger than ever and superman is still a
major part of their plans i could have
had
class i could have been a contender
i could have been somebody
superman had plenty of star power even
beyond the name recognition of its
fictional hero and no star in the cast
was bigger than marlon brando previously
brando had defined 50s youth culture and
the new school of method acting and
early hits such as on the waterfront and
a streetcar named desire and he was
bigger than ever in 1978 after his
oscar-winning performance in the
blockbuster gangster epic the godfather
that meant the ads for superman made
sure to put his involvement in the movie
front and center viewers could even be
forgiven for thinking he was the star so
they must have gotten a rude awakening
when after a brief brando-centric
prologue he disappears for most of the
movie only making a few more appearances
as a recording to mentor his son
altogether he only gets about 20 minutes
of screen time and he knocked out the
whole job in less than two weeks of
course at the height of his fame brandon
was able to command a hefty payday for a
few days work and with superman he
scored over 3 million and
11.75 percent of all the movies future
profits no wonder warner brothers wanted
to make the most of their investment by
hyping up the star's involvement
the producers behind superman had a lot
of faith in their movie and so they made
an unprecedented gamble on its success
before they even knew for sure that one
superman movie could sell they committed
themselves to two filming both the film
and its sequel simultaneously that may
not seem unusual now that every major
movie gets at least a sequel or two but
in 1978 it was unheard of star wars was
still just a single movie in 1978 and
only a few films had ever been
successfully franchised and most of
those few like the james bond and
godzilla franchises were pretty clearly
making things up as they went the
closest precedent was the godfather part
2 and there's a huge difference between
a character-driven historical epic and
an action franchise but superman did
learn from the godfather no doubt
because the 2-series shared a
screenwriter in mario puzo like puzzo's
other movies and unlike previous
franchises superman treated both movies
as one big story a long sequence at the
beginning deals with terence stamp as
the kryptonian criminal general zod who
wouldn't become important until superman
2. if the sequel had never been made
it's easy to imagine audiences
scratching their heads over what he was
even doing there granted some behind the
scenes drama eventually forced director
richard donner to focus on just the
first film and he was ousted when it
came time to finish part two but even if
superman didn't quite invent the sequel
teaser it came close and audiences
apparently ate it up superman 2 was the
number one movie in the world when it
hit theaters in 1981. check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]